I'm in the archives of the Royal Society
in London and unusually for one of our
videos I've got guests here and the
guest is Michael from the YouTube
channel Vsauce and I've never seen it
but Brite is really keen on it and peps
afterwards I watched one or two of his
videos yeah give us some more views that
they'd be awesome it's a pleasure maybe
you could even subscribe perhaps
I wanted to do was to show Michael
something that I think is really quite
interesting and which soon is going to
be completely unnecessary what we've got
here are standard weights this one here
is the standard pound for those of you
who are watching in other countries
outside England a pound is just under
four hundred and sixty grams here you
can see it says standard pound 1855 and
in sight here is a glass container and
inside that is the standard pound now
have a look at this might put out your
hand so you can feel there and the pound
itself is labeled 1844 so it took them
11 years to make this box and the idea
of a standard weight is that you have a
weight that's a reference so if you have
a pound weight on your balance you can
bring it here and see whether it weighs
the same as this standard now of course
when it was really the standard you
wouldn't be able to touch it because as
soon as you touched it then the grease
of your fingers would change the weight
especially your greasy fingers like yeah
they're not letting me touch it
except that one little time we're not
quite sure what this one is made out of
but there's another one here which is
slightly different oh I love this kind
of stuff I actually the first time I
ever came to London I ran to Trafalgar
Square first place I went to go to see
the foot they have a I think it also has
a yard correct
yeah and it's made out of metal and it's
embedded into this wall and at a
particular temperature it's an exact
foot if you ever said hey I built this
new type of ruler I want to make sure I
did it right you would take it to that
location so a foot is thirteen and a
half centimeters for those of you who
understand only modern units I'm marking
this english-american kind of metric
thing going on here what's funny is that
I'm sitting here oh and I use feet and
inches every day in America but if I
want to go see where the
exact definitions of the war I have to
go to England yeah this one here is
labeled the Royal Society's Troy pound
the Troy pound is a slightly different
pound it is used for measuring the
weights of precious metals and in here
there's rather beautiful brass cylinder
can you see and this one undoes there's
another part inside it's like a Russian
doll and inside that is a lump of
platinum that's pure platinum yes but
they've thought about the problem of us
holding it with our fingers so there's a
fork so we can lift it up Wow so now if
I hold it you can hold the fork yeah and
so this one is made out of platinum and
platinum is a very stable metal doesn't
react with air at room temperature so it
stays shiny and you don't need to worry
but you still mustn't touch it what do
you reckon that's way about I'd say one
troy ounce I'm really good at this kind
of even when I'm holding the very
scientific definition of it I get it
wrong alright just don't put this up on
YouTube here but what's really
interesting is that although there still
is a standard kilo which is kept in
Paris
very soon we won't need it anymore
because experiments being done to
measure the weight of silicon atoms the
group in Russia have made a very pure
sample of the isotope of silicon called
silicon 29 and then another group in
Australia has grown a big crystal which
has been machined into a sphere a round
ball and they can measure the size of
this ball very accurately and using
x-rays they can measure the separation
between the layers of atoms with a bit
of calculation
they can work out pretty accurately the
number of atoms inside this ball and
when they weigh the ball they then know
how much the atoms weigh and so in the
end we will be able to define weight not
in terms of the weight of a piece of
metal but a weight of a number of atoms
in the end the fundamental constant will
probably not be the kilo but Avogadro's
number
that is the number of atoms in 29 grams
of silicon 29 why does silicon 29 get to
be so special I think because it I don't
know but I guess it's first of all
because you can get pure silicon 29 and
then you can make a ball that is very
stable okay and isn't going to lose
atoms while you're weighing it and
things like that
the trouble is this feels really good
this is science in action and you can
understand this but a ball of silicon
locked away somewhere it's not as
exciting okay that's a wrap